[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peter king joins us right now football
morning and america columnist
nbcsports.com
best show on tv to you peter is what
uh
great british baking show
okay i don't know i like the great
british baking show
it's a great show
been been on a long time yeah and uh
look we we're we're uh
we're not i i've missed so many of these
shows it's almost intimidating when you
start to when somebody says hey have you
seen this this and this
i haven't even seen breaking bad yet
i mean i i got a long way to go i'm
stuck on the sopranos yeah and then if
you do breaking bad you got to do better
call saul
yeah you know so that's the prequel to
that yeah you got a lot well you're
always working pete you're always on uh
on the uh the football i'm not really
i'm not really dan life is a little bit
slowed down now around draft time life
stinks because
you just get competitive and you want to
get as many of these right as you can
and it's eminently frustrating but
anyway i got a big big sigh of relief
today because there's nothing else i can
do right now okay if i said i'm gonna
give you a crystal ball and you could
find out what this one team would be
doing for the draft the entire draft
what team would that be that you would
want to know
uh
you know it's a weird team because i'd
really want to know the pittsburgh
steelers okay because
i have a feeling at 20 they're going to
go quarterback i said kenny pickett
won't shock me at all if they go malik
willis
um but
pittsburgh is such an interesting team
because they are
they take great pride
in hiding everything that they do
and i applaud them for that that you
know secrets really don't get out of
that building i'd probably be most
curious about what the steelers are
going to do at 20.
i know that you hinted at maybe a
surprise at the top of the draft i saw
where the the new betting favorite
according to las vegas is uh trayvon
walker out of georgia it's is that a
surprise to you
well i've been hearing it for a couple
of weeks now so i wouldn't say it's that
big of a surprise
i don't know if it's going to happen dan
but
i think that
you know the guy who's got the most
power in that building honestly is trent
balke
um he always has been a tools guy
with you know at the top of the draft
you saw what what he did and it's
alden smith is used as the great
comparison because he picked alden smith
over j.j watt if alden smith didn't have
all the problems that he had in his
personal life
he could have been he could have had the
impact
long term that j.j watt has had could he
have won three dpo wise probably not but
he could have been a great player
and so
i think and i think there is something
to it some of the plays you've seen
trayvon walker make on tape are
incredible but
you know he has not made nearly the
number of plays that aiden hutchinson
has made in his college career and that
is what is really kind of a different
deal right now
and i had a source tell me that
hutchinson is the safer pick walker has
the higher ceiling here yeah and i
wonder about that um
you know what chris long well chris long
was the second pick overall out of
virginia and wasn't he considered a
safe pick for the rams now i think
that's a really good comparison
because he basically was
the guy who
uh
you know who who everybody thought was
the safest pick now aiden hutchinson
you might call him a safe pick but man
he had he's made some explosive plays
in college too i
i personally think that aiden hutchinson
will have the longer and better career
but dan if you ask me what what player
in this draft
five years from now we're going to look
back and say well that is the best
player out of this i'd say it's derrick
stingley and derek stingley could last
past 10. yeah
i loved him his freshman year in fact i
talked to ed orgeron i said i could see
him winning the heisman having him be a
two-way player i i was that impressed
with him the freshman in his freshman
year um and it was a while ago uh that i
had a source say sauce gardener is a top
five pick and i thought okay
and then you started to watch cincinnati
and then all of a sudden it feels like
sauce gardener could be a top ten maybe
a top five pick so you like stingley
over uh gardner well i it i i like him
over the long term better but
i think that sauce gardener going before
him is probably going to happen and it's
justified
sauce gardener
basically has played 1100
snaps
of past coverage in his college career
and in single coverage did not allow one
touchdown
and how do you not want to pick him
i
mean obviously it gets tougher at the
next level but to me
i think what he is
right now is he's more of a sure thing
and as somebody described to me over the
weekend uh somebody described uh
stingley as uh darrell rivas
and and i think the one thing about
stingley
that people say is that
he is a very confident
player and that confidence is justified
by how he plays and one other thing dan
he practiced
probably
75 to 100 times
uh day to day
covering jamar chase
in 2019
and you know like that's as tough as it
gets
and so i i think he's trained well
he had a foot injury obviously last year
and that's better i i think i think i
think stingley is going to be a real
good pro we're talking to peter king
football morning in america i know
you're uh joining us from berkeley
california how big of a story is debo
samuel
i mean it's a huge story especially if
he sticks to his guns
and he says he wants out and he's not
going to back down as you know dan
about 25 percent if that of guys who
ever say
uh i want out i'm not playing here ever
again
uh blah blah blah i mean
guys say that all the time
and then
five months later
they're back in camp or they're back
playing for the team they said they'd
never play with again
so
i don't i don't mean that i think debo
samuel is lying or anything like that i
just think that
opinions change opinions become less
hardened over time
um
and whether the 49ers are going to do
something i'd be really surprised if
they did something by the draft this
week
uh but we'll see
why does he want out
i don't know the answer to that and i
think
that people
excuse me people who know him
say that he's a little bit more of a
homebody
and
that this very well could be about the
fact that he just wants to be closer to
south carolina
you know where he's you know the
carolinas where he's from
but uh
i i don't i don't know how hard he is in
his position
um and it just it seems a little odd too
because a year ago
you know mike mcdaniel then the
offensive coordinator said
if you do everything i tell you you're
going to be first team all pro
and he did everything that mcdaniel told
him to do
and he was first team all-pro and i i
personally wonder about the absence of
the guy who
even he said debo said is his favorite
coach that he's ever had
so you know we'll see if that plays into
it
baker mayfield more likely to get traded
during the draft or after the draft i
think after i
it wouldn't make any sense to me
first of all i don't know what you what
you really get for baker mayfield i keep
wondering could this be a brock osweiler
kind of trade it's a weird
it's a weird situation that they're in
everybody knows that he can't go back
there
but you don't want to make him just a
free agent as jeff darlington said last
week mike florio's been talking about it
for weeks
that the pittsburgh steelers would just
go ahead and sign him how weird would it
be
if the steelers take
picketer willis at number 20 and and
they've got mitchell trubisky on their
team and two weeks later sometime baker
mayfield with the cleveland browns
paying their sal pay in his salary
that's why i don't think the browns are
going to release him
because they want to have some control
over where he goes yeah i wonder what
he's worth and then is cleveland gonna
have to pick up the tab with his salary
uh do you think does it they're gonna
have to pick up most if not all
um because they're the ones who said
we're gonna pick up the option there's
not a lot of teams that have the cap
space to do it now anyway
i just don't see any way right now that
uh that they can get away with
making a deal for him
without picking up most of the of the
salary
how difficult is it to try to do a mock
draft and factor in
the draft history of certain teams
certain teams are really good at
drafting and certain teams are not
here's the thing dan the thing i thought
was hardest about this year i wish i had
written about it because i thought about
it a few times
look at all of the people
near the top of the draft
who have no draft history
or very little
you know
trent balke has some
which which is helpful
brad holmes in detroit at number two
dan campbell they have virtually no
draft history
um nick casario he's got three and
thirteen
virtually no draft history joe douglas
at four and ten a little draft history
joe shane five and seven
no draft history whatsoever i mean so
that's one of the things you can't say
well you know three years ago this gm
did this and this there are so many new
and neophyte general managers who are in
control of this draft that's one of the
reasons why it's so hard to figure it
out
pete always great to talk to you thanks
for joining us and uh safe travels hey
appreciate it dan thank you that's peter
king football morning in america